[Musique]
merci
au cours des 25 dernières années, j'ai été
impliqué dans des incendies de forêt. Auparavant,
cela se produisait tous les 10 à 12 ans. Ce qui se
passe maintenant, c'est la façon dont l'
environnement et les changements de température
de la planète se produisent.  Nous
commençons à voir ces incendies de
forêt se produire au Royaume-Uni, en particulier dans le
sud-est, sur une base presque annuelle.
Nous traitons donc maintenant les
incendies de forêt comme d'habitude et les
conditions vont devenir plus extrêmes
au cours des deux prochaines décennies.  sur
[Musique]
étrangère
au Royaume-Uni, ils sont encore trop
secs en été, donc je
dirais certainement que si vous pouvez prendre un pique-nique
plutôt qu'un barbecue jetable,
éliminez simplement ce risque que vous savez ne pas utiliser
les barbecues.  Ne faites pas de feux de camp et
ramenez tous vos déchets à la maison. C'est pourquoi un
simple message pourra, espérons-le, réduire
le risque d'incendies de forêt dans le Surrey,
merci
[Musique]